I'm just here with my good friend Elmo.
Yeah.
I know-
Just hanging out.
Yes, because we both have talk shows.
That's true!
Which is so wonderful.
Elmo's learning a lot, this is a much bigger talk show,
this is a swanky place.
(audience laughs)
We just do Elmo's talk show in his apartment.
I gotta tell you, I know your set,
'cause I've been there firsthand and it's magnificent.
You have a big slide.
Yeah, but Elmo's not sure how we got it into the apartment
and Elmo's not really sure how we're gonna get it out.
But we do what we can with what we have.
I think your show is gonna be on for so long,
you're never gonna have to worry about it.
Really?
(audience cheers and applauds)
Well, Elmo, someone who's coming on
is someone that I really look to
as a really wonderful interviewer.
Oh, cool!
Yeah, she's a young journalist
and someone I hold very dear to my heart
and she gave us so many amazing moments last season.
And here's our little love letter
to our member of The Drew Crew.
(upbeat music)
She is a budding young journalist.
I love asking questions.
And an internet sensation.
I'm tell you guys a joke, bit's kind of inappropriate.
She's the eight year old girl
behind 7 Questions with Emmy.
The best journalist in the business.
And a very special member of Drew's Crew,
it's Emmy Eaton.
Are you ready to get into some stories?
Yes, yes, yes, I'm so excited.
She's already interviewed Keith Morrison,
Lester Holt, Dr. Oz, and on our show last season,
she grilled Seth Meyers and Willie Geist.
Seth, is it really hard to make people laugh every day?
Only my wife.
(Drew laughs)
Armed with her quick wit and curiosity,
Emmy is here to deliver all the good news.
We need more Emmy. The world needs more Emmy.
(audience applauding)
And the dream comes true!
Please welcome, for the first time ever,
in the actual studio, live and in person, it's Emmy Eaton.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Ah, Emmy, I'm so glad that you're finally here
in New York City!
I'm so glad I finally got to see you in person Drew.
Oh my gosh, I've been waiting for this moment
and I can't think of a more special occasion,
than to have our first time in person
get to be then with none other than Elmo.
Hi Elmo!
Hi, hi, hi!
Nice to meet you.
You too. My little brother Elliot loves you-
Really?
So much, yes.
Hi Elliot, Elmo loves you too.
Okay. I mean, I heard that you had some questions for Elmo
and I'd like you to take over this interview.
Okay.
Question number one, how old are you?
Forty four.
(Drew and Emmy giggling)
No, Elmo's just kidding! No, Elmo's three and a half.
Question number two.
Okay.
What's your favorite food?
Hmm.
Well, if Elmo's being a good monster, Elmo says apples.
But don't tell anybody, pizza.
(Elmo and Emmy laugh)
You and Ross Matthews, Elmo.
Really?
Mm-hmm.
(Elmo laughs)
You're gonna have to come and try New York pizza,
it's really good.
Oh, okay, maybe we can go for some pizza.
Yeah!
Okay, cool.
Who is your best friend on Sesame Street?
See Emmy, this is a very difficult question.
Because if Elmo says Cookie Monster,
Grover says, "Hey, wait a minute,
you said Cookie Monster was your favorite?"
So Elmo loves everybody equally.
I think that's a great answer, actually. I really do.
Because I think you don't wanna hurt anybody's feelings.
And how can you decide?
Yeah.
I know.
Big Bird, Bert and Ernie, Rosita, Abby, there's so many.
I agree.
Yeah.
I have a bunch of best friends too,
and they always asked me if they're my favorite,
and I say all of them.
Yeah, that's right, you can't say, right?
Yeah.
And you love everybody for different reasons.
Yeah. What makes you laugh?
Well, Elmo's friends make Elmo laugh.
Yeah.
Yeah, Cookie Monster makes Elmo laugh, Big Bird.
And you know, Elmo's ticklish, that's kind of Elmo's thing,
so that makes Elmo laugh too.
My little brother makes me laugh,
because he always, when your show comes on,
he always goes, "Elmo, Elmo!"
And then he thinks you're there in real life,
so then he is like, "Come give me a hug!"
And then he gets so sad that you're not there.
(Elmo cries)
That makes Elmo sad too.
Elliot, Elmo wants you to know
that you can come to Sesame Street anytime
and Elmo with give you a hug.
What advice do you have for me?
Advice?
Boy, well Elmo thinks you're doing really well already.
Elmo thinks you have great questions,
you have really good listening and Elmo just thinks
you should keep doing what you're doing,
'cause you're gonna go really far.
Thank you Elmo.
You're welcome!
I have to agree.
And I think it's a miracle that all three of us
are together, because we're all curious.
Yeah.
That's true.
And if we can bring that to our shows,
then we can be very good at our jobs
and ask people questions.
And maybe when those people give answers,
we can all have really good takeaways from them.
Yeah.
Very true.
Elmo can't say it better than that, that was perfect.
Oh my goodness. Well, thank you!
That was perfect!
(audience applauding)
Thank you Elmo and thank you Emmy, my love!
Emmy, yay!
(audience applauding)
The Not So Late Show With Elmo returns on September 30th
and is available to stream on HBO Max.
(upbeat theme music)